herzlich willkommen zur zdf heute live
bisher galt für die meisten von uns wer
sich mit corona infiziert der muss
verpflichtend in isolation anordnung vom
gesundheitsamt zehn tage
nach frühestens sieben tagen kann man
sich frei testen das soll sich nun alles
ändern bundesweit die pflicht zur
isolation soll reduziert werden auf nur
noch fünf tage darauf haben sich bund
und länder geeinigt also nach fünf tagen
ende der absonderung und was ist mit dem
frei testen ganz ohne test raus aus der
isolation und was ist wenn man nach fünf
tagen noch symptome hat dann einfach
trotzdem nach den fünf tagen zur arbeit
gehen sich unter menschen mischen ist
das nicht alles ein bisschen riskant was
da geplant ist wir wollen darüber
diskutieren mit zwei menschen die
unterschiedliche ansichten haben zum
einen den bayerischen
gesundheitsminister klaus rotte check
wir begrüßen ihn in maisach bei münchen
grüße nach bayern schön dass sie mit
dabei sind
und wir begrüßen auch den biologen
martin stürmer in frankfurt und freuen
uns auch auf seine ansichten einem
schönen guten abend ja und wenn es
fragen gibt dann einfach her damit wir
wollen sie gemeinsam mit unseren gästen
diskutieren zunächst aber ein überblick
über das was bisher gilt und das was
gelten sollen
wer sich mit corona infiziert hat für
den gilt in den meisten bundesländern
automatisch zehn tage isolation aus der
kann man sich nach einer woche frei
testen in manchen ländern wie bayern
oder sachsen kann die isolation bereits
nach fünf tagen beendet werden sofern
man schon zwei tage lang symptomfrei ist
einen negativen test braucht man dazu
nicht und in hessen endet die
isolationen generell nach fünf tagen
ohne negativen test und selbst für
diejenigen die noch symptome haben der
bundesgesundheitsminister
kritisiert dass ich persönlich glaube
dass am ende rund fünf tagen das ja sehr
kurze zeit eine selbst testung zumindest
eine selbstrettung drinnen sein müsste
weil wir wissen dass viele nach dem
fünften tag noch positiv sind und die
würden dann ja doch noch andere
anstecken daher ist eine also die
testung auch für diejenigen die keine
symptome mehr haben sinnvoll
deshalb will lauterbach kommende woche
einen vorschlag für eine neuregelung
vorlegen demnach müssten alle nach einer
corona infektion egal in welchem
bundesland nur noch fünf tage in
isolation um die zu beenden will
lauterbach einen negativen selbst test
werde ihn auch tatsächlich macht kann
aber niemand kontrollieren
herr minister sie haben mit lauterbach
mit den anderen ministern kolleginnen
und kollegen gesprochen und gesungen
oder sich geeinigt deshalb die erste
frage eben an sie lauterbach sagt es
aber die bundeszentrale für
gesundheitliche aufklärung selbst sagt
dass auch die ansteckungsfähigkeit die
endet so langsam nach zehn tagen da geht
sie deutlich zurück nach zehn aber nicht
nach fünf tagen und die gleiche behörde
sagt dass manche menschen auch deutlich
länger als zehn tage ansteckend sein
können wie kann man denn dann einfach
sozusagen diese sicherheit nehmen und
sagen nach fünf tagen ist alles okay ist
die isolation beendet ohne test ohne als
also erstmal folgen wir tatsächlich
einen vorschlag des el kaidas ja schon
im april eigentlich die fünf tage
empfohlen hat wir waren ja damals nur
noch strittig im kern ob wir die
isolation in die freiwilligkeit geben
sollen oder weiterhin eine anordnung des
gesundheitsamtes nötig ist und wir
bleiben bei der anordnung da waren wir
uns gestern auch einige isolation ist
keine privatsache und bei den fünf tagen
erfolgen wir der empfehlung des rk ii
jetzt gibt es immer unterschiedliche
meinungen was das frei testen angeht
einige länder tun wir es nicht mehr oder
nur noch bei grün nach allen gruppen
also in kranken und pflegebereich da
machen wir das auch wir empfehlen zb
wenn man 48 stunden symptomlos ist
trotzdem dann weitere fünf tage zum
beispiel eine ffp zwei maske im
innenraum mitzutragen als weiteres
sicherheits module aber der kern ist
eigentlich abgestimmt und viele länder
folgen jetzt diesen vorschlag der fünf
tage eben mit unterschiedlichkeit beim
thema frei testen bei dem thema publik
gruppen glaube ich nehmen aber viele
weiterhin den abschlusstest mit also sie
verteidigen das was jetzt beschlossen
worden ist dann fragen wir eben den
biologen herrn stürmer in hessen ist es
heute schon so wie es sein soll dass man
eben nach fünf tagen aus der isolation
heraus kommt egal ob man eben symptome
hat dann kann man zur arbeit gehen auch
am sechsten tag daneben ist man denn als
hesse dann weniger ansteckend
ja offensichtlich nein spaß beiseite ich
halte das natürlich für einen sehr
gewagten und sehr weitgehenden
regelung die ich auch in keinster form
unterstützen kann denn ich möchte selber
in meinem betrieb auch nicht mitarbeiter
haben die potentiellen noch infektiös
sind und mir andere leute anstecken die
mir dann wieder für möglicherweise noch
länger ausfallen weil sie massive
symptome haben also ich kann ehrlich
gesagt mit dieser fünf tage regelung
leben aber auch nur dann wenn wir sie
tatsächlich mit einer frei testung zwar
einer richtigen frei testung nicht
basierend auf einem schnelltest sondern
umgebung auf einem bürgerfest bewohnt
durchführen dann kann ich damit leben
ansonsten habe ich damit wirklich ein
problem das virologische sich
dann fragen wir den minister noch mal
weil sie es eben herold check ja selber
angesprochen haben in bayern und werden
es eben beitrag auch noch mal gezeigt in
bayern ist die bisherige jetzige
regelung dass man zumindest 48 stunden
symptomfrei sein muss jetzt wissen wir
aber alle haben die erfahrung gemacht im
bekanntenkreis in freunde das heißt dass
viele viele menschen positiv sind sie
sind auch ansteckend sie haben omikron
aber sie haben keine symptome der
minister habe ich so höre ich heute ist
positiv ihm geht es bestens er hat keine
symptome aber er ist positiv gehört also
auch zu denjenigen die im moment
symptomfrei sind aber eben positiv sind
da gibt es doch die bayerische forderung
im moment gibt doch auch überhaupt keine
sicherheit
also wie gesagt ich kann nur nochmals
sagen wir haben es ja diskutiert
ursprünglich war professor wieder auch
mit in diesem thema involviert und die
fünf tage waren damals tatsächlich
konsens vom lka auch nochmal so
empfohlen wir wollten bloß nicht dass
die isolation freiwillig in die
eigenverantwortung geht sondern dass es
eine anordnung des gesundheitsamtes gibt
das war das entscheidende was den
unterschied ausmachte wir haben immer
gesagt nach fünf tagen 48 stunden
symptomfrei soll weiterhin die s der p2
maske für weitere tage getragen und
waren uns einig dass wir bei den
verwundbaren gruppen tatsächlich noch
einmal den tests haben wollen weil das
auch noch ein besonderer schutz
mechanismus ist aber ansonsten folgen
wir im kern tatsächlich der wissenschaft
mit dem unterschied eben dieser frei
testung die karl lauterbach gestern aus
meiner sicht das erste mal noch mal ins
gespräch für die allgemeinheit gebracht
hat als eine empfehlung und eben als
nicht als eine absolute vorgabe also
glasklar sie verweisen eben auf das rk
ii was die experten dort sagen aber das
eigenartige ist ja eben und jetzt frage
ich nochmal den virologen stürmer eben
herr schirmer das lauterbach ja selbst
heute morgen im ard morgenmagazin gesagt
hat eben nach fünf tagen isolation
müsste doch eine selbsttötung dringend
empfohlen sein warum weil er ja warnt
weil wir wissen dass viele nach dem
fünften tag noch positiv sind also nach
fünf tagen noch positiv sind das risiko
ist ja nun ganz offenbar da und er sagt
dann müsste man einen selbsttest
empfehlen jetzt zweierlei dinge selbst
test dh den mache ich einfach zu hause
was halten sie denn davon und was halten
sie von der empfehlung ist ja ein
unterschied ob er das verpflichtend ist
oder empfohlen wird
also ich finde auch dass wir diese diese
fünf tage diskussion ich weiß gar nicht
wo das herkommt das waren auf einmal die
fünf tage für so unbedenklich erklärt
dass man damit eine isolation ohne
testung beenden kann das ist erst mal
mein erstes problem ich kann es mir nur
damit erklären dass man omikron
letztendlich für so harmlos hält das man
eher eine durchseuchung der bevölkerung
in kauf nimmt als der infektionsschutz
und dabei die möglichkeit von longo wird
völlig außer acht lässt bezüglich der
testung der selbsttest den kann ich ja
prinzip so gestalten wie ich haben
möchte ist das wetter schön ich freue
mich über fünf zusätzliche freie tage
durch mein arbeitgeber weil ich
weiterhin positiv bin dann mach ich dir
selbst das positiv möchte ich aber
wieder arbeiten und bin trotzdem krank
ist man schnell test negativ den ich zu
hause mache werde das überprüfen wir das
gewährleisten als das minimum was wir
dafür brauchen ist der bürger test weil
der uns zumindest eine gewisse
neutralität
verspricht so dass also eben nicht ich
selber diesen das durchführen kann und
das wäre für mich das absolute minimum
und wo ich mit dieser fünf tage regung
überhaupt konform gehen kann unabhängig
davon ob er wieder das in einer
besprechung ki mal propagiert hat oder
nicht ich halte das für dazu zu gewagt
ganz ehrlich herr holetschek das ist
deutlich weniger kurzem noch mal ein
hund darf
die fünf tage waren tatsächlich
eigentlich konsens und so hat das el
kaidas auch damals gesagt man muss
natürlich auch sehen wir wollen weiter
die anordnung des gesundheitsamtes bei
der isolation das halte ich auch nach
wie vor für richtig und der nächste
schritt ist natürlich jetzt ein weg mehr
in die eigenverantwortung ob das jetzt
eine empfehlung einer selbsttests ist
oder die empfehlung noch mal fünf tage
auch im innenraum eine ffp zwei maske zu
tragen in der allgemeinheit das ist ein
schritt in eine eigenverantwortung
hinein wie man jetzt im lichte der
entwicklung geht und die möglicherweise
auch im herbst wieder überprüft werden
muss ich machen
aber im moment
eine verständnis frage herr minister
herr lauterbach ich deshalb müssen sie
das erste mal ein auch dann war ich dann
nicht mehr ganz mit komm herr lauterbach
der bundesgesundheitsminister sagt
einerseits heute morgen im gleichen
interview generell mache es einen großen
unterschied ob die bürger wüssten ob sie
unbedingt zu hause bleiben müssten oder
ob sie frei zu entscheiden sei diese
isolation zu hause sie machen das ja
auch gerade deutlich dass sie sagen
jawohl wir sind doch ganz strikt das
kommt per anordnung weiterhin vom
gesundheitsamt warum weil es eben doch
eine andere wirkung hat wenn es
verpflichtet ist wenn es eine anordnung
ist gleichzeitig aber ist es ebenso eine
pflicht ist also wenn man sagt die
pflicht ist besser als die eigene
verantwortung das sagt man hier bei
diesem argument und dann geht man eben
hin und sagt beim frei testen das ist
dann keine verpflichtung mehr sondern
das ist dann nur eine empfehlung sprich
also da eigenverantwortung das passt
doch nicht zusammen da einerseits zu
sagen die pflicht ist besser als die
eigenverantwortung was für mehr
sicherheit sorgt und auf der anderen
seite sagt man könne frei testen
eigenverantwortung
also ich will das noch mal deutlich
machen die fünf tage sind weiter keine
privatsache sondern werden angeordnet
wir heben die isolation nicht auf wir
verkürzen sie riecht auf fünf tage in
bayern zusätzlich 48 stunden
symptomfreiheit und dann endet das wenn
die symptome weiter sind geht auch die
isolation weiter längstens bis zu zehn
tagen aber der übergang von den fünf
tagen dann ist natürlich dann auch ein
stück eigenverantwortung viele leute
machen vielleicht auch weiter einen
selbsttest zu ihrer eigenen sicherheit
weil die sagen ja ganz verwaist sein das
ist tatsächlich dann sagt er stoner ein
der es nicht mehr verpflichten das ist
dann ein übergang in ein stück
eigenverantwortung aber die fünf tage
die sind weiter natürlich als isolation
auch angeordnet was sagen sie denn zu
dem vorwurf den hersteller jetzt gesagt
hast das riecht doch nach einer
gewollten durchseuchung
also ich schätze herrn schon mal sehr
weil seine meinung in der pandemie immer
wichtig war und wir in verschiedenen
diskussionen auch immer wieder zusammen
waren wir wollen keine durchseuchung wir
wollen eine verantwortbare lösung
orientieren uns bei den fünf tagen an
einer empfehlung des lka ich will das
noch mal sagen die fünf tage form von
der verkürzung sind konsens gewesen und
sind jetzt auch ins team bundesländern
schon umgesetzt wir machen das seit 13
april und 10 eigentlich eher dass die
zahlen sicher positiver entwickeln als
dass wir jetzt tatsächlich eine welle
auf uns zukommen sind dann kommen wir
auf einen punkt den sie beide ja auch
schon indirekt ein bisschen angesprochen
haben und zwar das problem bald zwischen
arbeitgeber und arbeitnehmer wenn jetzt
jemand corona hat und nach fünf tagen
noch symptome hat aber die nach fünf
tagen die isolation pflicht automatisch
endet wie das jetzt ja in hessen schon
der fall ist was macht denn dann
derjenige der vom arbeitgeber wieder zur
arbeit gerufen wird obwohl er vielleicht
symptome hat oder umgekehrt was macht
der arbeitgeber wenn jemand sagt wir
euch habe sondern auch symptome aber
fünf tage sind rum ich komme wieder zur
arbeit und der arbeitgeber würde das am
liebsten eigentlich verhindern dass
arbeitnehmer nach fünf tagen noch
symptome haben und krankgeschrieben sind
dann müssen sie natürlich nicht zur
arbeit gehen wenn diese isolation
pflicht aber tatsächlich nach fünf tagen
entfällt dann werden arbeitnehmer ab
diesem zeitpunkt theoretisch wieder frei
müssten also auch zur arbeit gehen denn
das drei tasten soll nach aktuellen
informationen nur noch dringend
empfohlen werden heißt es gibt dann
keine pflicht mehr zum zweiten glas aber
auch wenn arbeitnehmer sich nach fünf
tagen testen und noch positiv sind dann
trifft den arbeitgeber eine
fürsorgepflicht für seine anderen
mitarbeiter er muss dann für
infektionsschutz am arbeitsplatz sorgen
wie er das macht es dann seine sache
aber da wäre natürlich das home-office
sinnvoller als der gang zur arbeit ich
kann mich als arbeitnehmer nicht direkt
dagegen wehren wenn ein kollege noch
positives oder symptome und ins büro
zurückkommt aber der arbeitgeber der
muss ein hygiene konzept aufstellen und
damit ist der arbeitnehmer auf jeden
fall für infektionen am arbeitsplatz
geschützt wie ihr arbeitgeber das macht
er hat der arbeitnehmer aber keinen
einfluss drauf
wenn es kitschig klingt erstmal nach
sehr viel chaos in der arbeitswelt oder
naja das entscheidende ist nach wie vor
das thema der krankschreibung bei
symptomen damit ist eine klare regelung
das andere ist tatsächlich so dass wir
auch empfehlen dass man die maske zum
beispiel im innenraum weiter trägt dass
man auf das home office dann setzt noch
für gewisse zeiten ich glaube das kann
man schon aus steuern wenn man das
vernünftig angeht und wie gesagt wenn
ich symptome haben dann sollte ich
daheim bleiben sollte ich zum arzt gehen
und dann bin ich auch krank geschrieben
tja wenn es da also ganz herzlichen dank
für ihre einschätzung und wir haben es
verstanden sie haben eben diese
information vom rk ii bekommen und
folgen sozusagen diesem rat das ist
deutlich geworden ganz herzlichen dank
aus termingründen müssen wir sie
sozusagen entlassen und dankt aber ganz
herzlich dass sie teilgenommen haben
einen schönen namen noch überlegt
alles
ja und martin stürmer der virologe in
frankfurt hat etwas mehr zeit für uns
und insofern können wir auch noch fragen
beantworten und das ganze diskutieren
die frage auch an sie herr stürmer jetzt
hat unsere liebe kollegin laurin busche
von der redaktion recht und justiz und
das gerade mal erklärt und das hört sich
ja nun ziemlich kompliziert an wenn
tatsächlich jemand sagen kann die fünf
tage sind rum ich habe zwar noch
symptome schliefen ein bisschen aber ich
gehe jetzt einfach zur arbeit was sagen
dann die kollegen was macht der
arbeitgeber
drängen sich da ihnen auch fragen auf
einige ich stelle mir das wie sie es
gesagt haben chaotisch vor ich glaube
nicht dass er das so einfach regeln
können viele berufssparten da kann man
keinen home office anbieten ja da müssen
die leute zur arbeit kommen wenn sie
arbeitsfähig sind bisher für
arbeitsfähig deklariert werden ich
verstehe einfach die die die zielführung
nicht warum ich ein ein system was
einfach gehalten werden kann mit einer
vernünftigen frei testung und dann habe
ich eben einen sicheren arbeitnehmer der
zur arbeit kommt für alle beteiligten
was daran so schwierig ist anstatt mich
in so ein regelchaos mit in der
arbeitswelt zu stürzen dass das gibt an
meinem verständnis vorbei ich hätte eine
rolle check auch sehr und ich habe seine
argumentation auch verstanden dass sie
natürlich irgendwo den den maßgaben des
ak ii folgt nur ich möchte das einfach
mal kritisch hinterfragt sehen weil mir
kommt dass gerade so ein bisschen ein
bisschen komisch vor das ganze weil auf
der einen seite sagt man die
infektiosität nach fünf tagen ist ist
sicherlich noch gegeben und auf deiner
seite macht man eine solche vorschläge
das passt für mich in keiner form
irgendwo zusammen und deswegen kann ich
nur appellieren dass man zumindest wenn
man dieser fünf tage regelung folgt dem
nächsten schritt tut und das ganze für
alle beteiligten in irgend einer
vernünftigen regelbaren und und meiner
meinung nach relativ einfach umsetzbaren
form absichert
jetzt haben wir noch nicht mehr dabei
die politik leider länder und der bund
so ist zu hören haben sich eben auf
diese fünf tage isolation geeinigt und
verweisen dabei auf die zunehmende
immunität in der bevölkerung sowie
mildere krankheitsverläufe bei der
omicron variante das ist zumindest zu
hören auch als begründung was sagt der
virologe dazu hat sich irgendwas
geändert
bubikon ist natürlich insgesamt mit
deutlich weniger schweren verläufen
assoziiert jedoch die zu vorherigen
varianten aber was vielleicht auch in
ihrem umfeld in meinem umfeld häufiger
vorkommen dass die sie sich jetzt mit
omikron anstecken zwar nicht ins
krankenhaus müssen aber für zehn tage
völlig flach liegen das heißt also ich
habe das problem wenn ja auch ein
arbeitgeber das mir die ausfälle
letztendlich fast zehn tage lang fehlen
im labor und das muss man auch mal
berücksichtigen also wenn ich jetzt so
eine regelung treffe und infizierte
mitarbeiter infektiöse mitarbeiter
kommen wieder zur arbeit dann ist ein
risiko da das andere mitarbeiter eben
krank werden und nicht einfach mal die
infektion locker wegstecken sondern zehn
tage flach liegen und das möchte ich
gerne vermeiden und das gilt
wahrscheinlich nicht nur mir so insofern
ist das was die krankenhaus belastung
angeht in dieser fragestellung erst war
sekundär zu sehen
jetzt wollen wir uns mal ein bisschen
anhören in anführungsstrichen anschauen
was denn so die meinung in der
bevölkerung ist ja können einfach mal
schauen auf eine frage die das zdf
politbarometer gestellt hat den
bürgerinnen und bürgern und das sind die
ergebnisse die wir heute erfahren haben
den wegfall der meisten corona maßnahmen
finden 48 prozent der befragten richtig
und 51 prozent nicht richtig das heißt
also es ist immer doch noch eine
mehrheit die hälfte der bevölkerung die
weiterhin vorsicht lassen walten möchte
die frage ist warum die politik da eben
einen anderen weg geht wir können auch
noch mal weiterschauen
hier sehen wir einerseits halten sie
ihre gesundheit durch das corona virus
für gefährdet da sagt nun eine mehrheit
nicht wirklich das spiegelt sich dann
eben auch hier wieder omikron weniger
gefährlich weniger menschen auf
intensivstationen
allerdings und das ist jetzt sehr
spannend sagen die bürger bei der frage
wird es im herbst zu einer weiteren
corona welle kommen da gehen 86 prozent
davon aus ja und nur 9 9 prozent sagen
nein das heißt ein bisschen herr stürmer
drängt sich die frage auf ist es nicht
so dass die bürger und ein bürger sagen
jawohl da wird wieder eine welle kommen
und irgendwie ist das nicht eine art
déjà vu erlebnis dass die politik jetzt
wenn es irgendwo gerade moeglich ist
zahlen runter gehen lockert und dann im
herbst stehen wir wieder vor einer wand
von infektionszahlen
ist es davon auszugehen dass wir wieder
deutlich steigende infektionszahlen im
herbst stehen werden die frage ist wie
wir damit umgehen als gesellschaft als
politik als wissenschaft es gibt
verschiedene möglichkeiten
wir haben letztendlich im herbst eine
eine mikrowelle die wir haben bis dahin
einen einen vernünftigen impfstoff der
auch an omikron ob promikon optimiert
worden ist wir wissen dass ronny krohn
und longo wird eigentlich relativ
untergeordnete rolle spielen dann werden
wir sicherlich relativ gut durch den
herbst und winter kommen können ohne
dass wir wieder respektive maßnahmen
ergreifen müssen ich kann aber genauso
gut passieren dass wir eben die hände in
den schoß legen und so tun als ob nichts
passiert nichts vorbereiten und
letztendlich im herbst wieder da stehen
und dann wieder mit maßnahmen anfangen
zu agieren ich halte das für nicht
notwendig wir haben alle möglichkeiten
wirklich omikron als die chance zu sehen
und als fonds zu nehmen uns zu
entspannen ich bin ja auch nicht
grundsätzlich gegen die rückführung von
maßnahmen mir ist es nur etwas zu früh
ich weiß noch zu wenig über omikron und
longo wird ich möchte vermeiden dass
zehn bis 15 oder sogar 30 prozent der
bevölkerung irgendwelche langzeit
komplikationen davontragen in
unterschiedlichem schweregrad und sage
ich dass ich weiß bin ich sehr
vorsichtig aber ich denke wir haben eine
chance jetzt den sommer nutzen zu können
um das virus weiter kennenzulernen noch
mehr erfahrung zu sammeln um vor allem
uns eben auf den herbst und winter gut
gut einzustellen ich denke dass wir mit
der guten impfstrategie guten
impfkampagne das ganze im herbst noch
mal sehr sehr gut absichern kann dass
wir nicht eben wieder in restriktive
maßnahmen zurückfahren müssen dann haben
sie eine frage schon so ein bisschen
beantwortet sich die ihre finger der ja
irgendwie brennt wie sieht es mit longo
wird ausbau nikon man sagt ja immer
milder verlauf milder verlauf manche
haben gar keine symptome aber sie haben
gerade gesagt im grunde dann ist sie gar
nicht richtig untersucht weil es ja die
neueste variante ist wie es mit längeren
mit langzeitfolgen eben aussieht also
insofern da tappen wir alle auch
psychologe noch im dunkel jetzt eine
frage jeder hat es vielleicht auch
beobachtet dass in den letzten tagen
wenn wir die zahlen vom rk ja weiter
transportiert haben da sind die zahl der
neuinfektionen ist nach oben gegangen
ist nach unten gegangen wir haben
versucht es zu interpretieren und zu
sagen das hängt vielleicht damit
zusammen dass es eben an ostern
verspätungen gibt dann wird was nach
gemeldet und so weiter geht es rauf und
runter jeder fragt sich glaube ich was
ist eigentlich auf diese zahlen noch zu
geben wie sicher wie belastbar sind die
wie oft wird eigentlich noch getestet
wie viele leute haben corona lassen sich
nicht testen wer niemals registriert wie
viele pcr test gehen bei ihnen im labor
ein
ja definitiv also ich bin eigentlich
immer ein verfechter der der sieben tage
systems gewesen weil ich sie als einen
sehr einfachen sehr früh greifen und
nachvollziehbaren parameter gesehen habe
aber ich bin inzwischen auch so weit
dass ich diese ganzen ihren der
schwankungen eigentlich gar nicht mehr
mehr beachten kann das hat verschiedene
gründe sie haben die feiertage
angesprochen damit fing das ganze an wir
haben über den durch den wegfall der
maßnahmen keine notwendigkeit mehr zum
testen ich brauche um am öffentlichen
leben teilnehmen zu können kein test
nachweis mehr welche motivation habe ich
dann noch überhaupt zum test zu gehen
wenn ich jetzt auch noch in die
isolation ohne test beenden kann gibt es
ja eigentlich fast kaum noch ein grund
überhaupt zu sagen ich lasse mich testen
damit ich überhaupt nicht mehr in die
isolation geben muss weil wenn sie ohne
probleme großartig beendet werden kann
da kann ich es auch lassen und wir sehen
tatsächlich einen deutlichen rückgang
bei uns im labor an den fallzahlen wir
sehen deutschlandweiten deutlichen
rückgang der test zahlen jetzt habe ich
mich gerade versprochen ich meine
natürlich nicht der fall sein sondern
der test zahlen wir hatten jetzt in der
kalenderwoche 15 grad noch etwas mehr
als 1,1 millionen tests pro woche in
ganz deutschland im vergleich zu über
zweieinhalb millionen in hochphasen der
pandemie also da ist natürlich ein ein
deutlich schräges und schwer nicht mehr
wirklich reproduzierbares abbild der
fallzahlen sichtbar und aus persönlichen
erfahrung sehe ich in meinem umfeld
sowohl beruflich als auch privat sehe
ich jetzt in den letzten wochen
eigentlich die meisten corona fälle
vergleich sogar ins ganz anderen zeiten
also jetzt habe ich das gefühl und ich
sehe ist eigentlich auch dass die
dunkelziffer sehr hoch ist
dann wollen wir einfach mal so zu sagen
die userinnen und user mit an bord holen
denn es gibt ganz interessante
kommentare eben auch erfahrungen die er
für alle interessant sind tom hans
schreibt über youtube ja ich finde das
eigentlich ganz gut gemacht dass man
wieder zur normalität findet das ist
jetzt der erste schritt und dann wird
irgendwann die isolationsschicht
wahrscheinlich komplett aufgehoben das
heißt er ist also in der tat für eine
kürzere isolations zeit da gibt es
allerdings auch hier andere meinungen
ampunkt endpunkt schreibt über youtube
nähe finde ich keine gute idee ich habe
nämlich momentan corona und mir geht es
nach tag 5 noch nicht ganz gut habe
immer noch müdigkeit trockener hals
husen etc und ich bin froh jetzt nach
diesen fünf tagen das ich sozusagen noch
krankgeschrieben bin und die zeit habe
wieder gesund zu werden juli beschreibt
über youtube ich war am elften tag noch
positiv also gestern heute am zwölften
tag zeigte er selbst heißt nur noch mit
viel fantasie einen hellgrauen schatten
ich finde jeder sollte mindestens noch
einen selbsttest machen bevor er loslegt
das ist ja auch kein problem also
zumindest auch einige bestätigungen dass
eben nach fünf tagen noch nicht
unbedingt zwei erwachsenen schluss ist
vielleicht können sie das auch erklären
bei kleineren kindern meine tochter hat
er jetzt mal corona mit zweieinhalb
jahren da war nach fünf tagen alles
wieder vorbei ist da auch vielleicht ein
unterschied zwischen jüngeren und
älteren was die zeit angeht
ja sicherlich läuft die infektion
erstmal natürlich alters gestaffelt
unterschiedlich je nachdem wie die
single system ausgeprägt ist und
natürlich auch individuell sehr
unterschiedlich also auch egal ob sie
noch bei kindern bei erwachsenen gucken
muss man dann natürlich grundsätzlich
einfach mit relativen zeitspanne rechnen
und klar diese fünf tage die jetzt in
der diskussion sind haben natürlich
irgendwo wahrscheinlich eine
berechtigung weil man halt irgendwo
gesehen hat wie viel prozent sind danach
fünf tagen noch positiv und wie viele
nicht mehr und daraus kann man natürlich
eine risikokalkulation ableiten und
sagen okay mit einem gewissen restrisiko
muss ich muss ich leben also das ist
wird sicherlich immer die ganze
bevölkerung hinweg berechnet worden sein
sich angeguckt worden sein ich teile
halt diese ansicht nicht das war das
risiko frei machen kann aber dafür haben
wir ja unsere unsere experten in
verschiedensten gremien und
werden sich sicherlich was dabei gedacht
haben auch wenn ich es wie gesagt
persönlich nicht gut finden aber es ist
eine individuell sehr unterschiedlicher
verlauf wir werden es nicht schaffen
eine hundertprozentige sicherheit zu
bekommen das muss man auch nicht ein
gewisses restrisiko wird es immer geben
und ich möchte auch noch eine eine sache
ansprechen was immer diese normalität
zurück zur normalität angeht ich bin
absolut dafür dass wir möglichst schnell
zur normalität zurückkehren ich bin der
letzte der an maßnahmen festklammert nur
weil es mir gefällt oder ich das toll
finde also ich freue mich auch wenn das
endlich vorbei ist ich finde nur dass
der zeitpunkt jetzt etwas ungünstig
gewählt ist weil wir einfach noch ein
paar wissenschaftliche argumente fehlen
um wirklich hundertprozentig sicher zu
sein dass die omikron variante hier
diejenige welche ist die es uns
ermöglicht in den endemischen zustand
also in den entspannungszustand mehr
oder weniger zurückkehren zu können ich
war da spricht der wissenschaftler eben
sagt ich möchte erstmal fundierte
erkenntnisse haben bevor ich
entscheidungen treffe ja und hier ist es
eben ganz spannend dass wir immer mehr
feedback bekommen erfahrungen eben auch
und die zeigen eben es ist nicht alles
generell bei fünf tagen so sondern
völlig unterschiedlich sein schreibt
über youtube hallo ich hatte schon
corona und ja nach fünf tagen hatte ich
dann eben auch einen negativen test
jetzt kommt aber die einschränkung auch
von ihm aber selbst in den zwei wochen
danach hat es etwas gedauert bis ich so
weit okay war dass ich wieder arbeiten
gehen konnte und melanie hat jahre
schreibt über facebook man muss sich
dennoch frei testen also dass dafür
plädiert sie so verstehe ich das und
nach fünf tagen ist man definitiv noch
positiv wo ist denn da der sinn alle
wirklich alle kollegen und kolleginnen
schreibt sie waren erst am achten tag
pcr test negativ 2 sogar erst nach über
zehn tagen also auch sie hat da so
einige bedenken zu glauben dass nach
fünf tagen das alles schon beendet ist
jetzt haben wir eine frage noch herr
stürmer und wollen sie als virologen
sozusagen diese frage stellen wie eine
fachfrage von barbara wolkow wie lange
bin ich eigentlich immun nach einer
erkrankung wenn wir jetzt schon beim
thema infektionen sind aber kommando
fragt soll ich mich impfen lassen nach
einer infektion
ich habe jetzt zwei impfungen gehabt wie
sieht das denn da aus wenn man eben
infiziert ist oder infiziert war
also auch hier ist das natürlich
individuell sehr unterschiedlich so
schnell und so langsam wie die infektion
verschwindet so lange so kurz kann
gegebenenfalls auch eine immunität
vor herrschen also ich denke so
grundsätzlich wenn man so über richtung
perspektivisch denken ich glaube
diejenigen die jetzt
entweder durch geimpft sind oder eben
noch mal eine infektion bekommen haben
können bis zum herbst warten bevor da
möglicherweise noch einmal eine nächste
impfung notwendig sein wird hängt ein
bisschen davon ab welche varianten
kommen und ob es tatsächlich schaffen
einen angepassten impfstoff auf den
markt zu bringen weil ich denke dann
macht es sinn dass wir uns im herbst
nochmal alle durch impfen damit wir
wirklich entspannt in den herbst und den
winter reingehen können so direkt nach
einer infektion bei 2 zur vorherigen
impfungen da ist es sicherlich aktuell
nicht notwendig da nochmal direkt nach
zu impfen es sei denn man gehört zu
einer gewissen risiko konstellation
sprich eine immunsupprimierten patient
also bei einem wo das immunsystem
insgesamt sehr sehr schwach ist und
nicht ordentlich funktioniert da mag es
sinn machen eben nochmal zwischen
impfung zu machen aber ich denke für die
menschen die im prinzip nicht zu der
risiko konstellation gehören kann man
definitiv bis zum herbst warten bevor
man jetzt noch mal zur impfung greift
denn dann wäre schon mal ganz herzlich
für den service also diese präzise frage
fach frage zu beantworten in der
zwischenzeit noch weitere kommentare die
doch auch ein bisschen in die skeptische
richtung gehen was jetzt die politik
plant zur kartell schreibt über male ich
bin seit elf tagen positiv auf corona in
nordrhein westfalen hätte ich nach zehn
tagen jetzt schon wieder das haus
verlassen können ich habe noch noch aus
vorsichtsgründen einen pcr test gemacht
und bin tatsächlich nach zehn tagen auch
noch positiv und sabine rometsch
schreibt über facebook kostenloser
pflicht test und zehn tage quarantäne so
strikt so wäre es richtig und ich werde
auf jeden fall weiter maske tragen das
ist ja etwas was man zumindest machen
kann wir haben aber auch gezeigt dass
das was die politik plant worauf sich
bund und länder einigt haben ja eine
schwierige sache ist zumindest für sehr
viel gespräch gesprächsbedarf hat und
wir haben durch sie auch gesehen herr
stürmer dass auch die ja sag ich mal
experten sind sich alle einig sind der
minister hologic hat sich eben auf das
lka berufen sie haben eine andere
meinung insofern ist das sehr spannend
heute gewesen vielen dank herr stürmer
dass sie mit dabei waren einen schönen
abend noch grüße nach frankfurt
ja und ich sage vielen vielen dank für
die rege teilnahme
das ist ja hoch spannend wenn man eben
gemeinsam die erfahrungen austauscht und
auch gemeinsam streiten kann und
argumente austauschen kann und die
unterschiedlichen meinungen hört das war
unser zdf heute live stream zu der
entscheidung dass die isolationsschicht
auf fünf tage reduziert werden soll
bundesgesundheitsminister lauterbach
wird entsprechenden vor einen
entsprechenden vorschlag nächste woche
erarbeiten vorstellen und dann so heißt
es wieder liegt es dann an den ländern
das ganze umzusetzen es bleibt also
spannend was dann nächste woche
passieren wird vielen dank für das
interesse